[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro tout de suite le sommaire
de ce vendredi 30 mars
à vos marques prêts chassé pour pas que
ce week end de nombreuses chasses aux
oeufs sont organisées dans les yvelines
notamment à france miniature le parc
ouvre ses portes samedi 31 mars pour une
nouvelle saison
le directeur sera avec nous pour nous
présenter des nouveautés à découvrir
entre art et cirque et lois de la
physique secrète en deux un spectacle
autour de l'équilibré notre perception
du mouvement
le metteur en scène johann le guillerm a
installé son chapiteau à jouy en josas
jusqu'au 12 avril deux semaines de
festival pour les tout petits à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines babillage
revient pour une sixième édition autour
du pop up
nous ferons le point avec mélanie sur la
programmation jusqu'au 14 avril le
chocolat coule à flots actuellement chez
les professionnels car nous préparons
accès dimanche et comme le veut la
tradition cacao de rigueur dans les
yvelines les chocolatiers se prépare
comme chez la maison kola située à maule
l'équipe a créé une collection sur le
thème des graines sculptures de petits
rongeurs ou peintures de tulipes en
chocolat l'art au service de la
gourmandise la graine j'ai trouvé que
c'est intéressant parce que le chocolat
ça provient de l'année de la graine du
cacaoyer de la cabosse le fera l'ine
c'est des noisettes des amendes de la
vanille tout ça ce sont des graines
donc on a travaillé sur ce thème là et
puis on a aussi une variété de formes
de géométrie est vraiment intéressante
sur ce thème de la graine et pour pâques
aussi ce week-end différentes chasse aux
oeufs sont organisées dans tout le
département les villes comme plaisir le
château de breteuil à choisel où le parc
de thoiry vous invite pour recueillir
vos chocolats à la ferme de gally ce
dimanche 1er avril c'est même une fête d
eux qui est proposé les participants
devront ramasser des oeufs de couleur
dans les prés des fermes à venir
échanger contre des chocolats des
ateliers sont également prévus
réalisation denis en paille peinture sur
oeufs ou encore découverte des
différents animaux et métiers de la
ferme
donc il va y avoir aussi des
démonstrations à l'ancienne typique de
la ferme donc le filage de la laine le
tourneur sur bois
l'apiculteur et surtout il y aura le
tondeur le berger thomas qui va venir
tondre tous nos moutons brebis et
béliers tout ce que l'on fait tout au
long de la baie mais en plus que les
enfants les parents soient acteurs
chasse aux oeufs aussi à elancourt le
parc france miniature n'y échappe pas il
rouvre ses portes ce samedi 31 mars
après sa pause hivernale et les
gourmands sont invités à découvrir ou
redécouvrir le parc saint-maurice la
loure directeur du site est avec nous
bonjour j'ai cabine alors pour le
week-end de pâques du samedi 31 mars au
lundi 2 avril les enfants peuvent
parcourir le domaine à la recherche des
oeufs
comme le veut la tradition c'est ça sur
nos cinq hectares que compte le parc en
fait on aura dissimuler des jeux de
couleurs ils ont proposé aux enfants de
découvrir sur le circuit de visite et
d'assembler ses yeux parce qu'il y aura
un code couleur à trouver et on échange
de ce code couleur viseront de cette
fois ci des vrais oeufs en chocolat à
découvrir à manger toute la déguster à
venir échanger du coup alors le parc
france miniature dont il a fermé ses
portes en durant l'hiver qu'est-ce que
vous avez préparé pollinisateurs c'est
une longue coupure pour nous pendant la
période hivernale mais c'est une période
nécessaire parce que ça nous permet de
remettre tous nos monuments en état il
ya un gros travail de préparation avant
une réouverture
il faut évidemment reprendre des
peintures reprendre les petits détails
que composent le parc il ya 117 monument
sur le parc donc ça nous offre beaucoup
de travail et le parc réhaussé porte en
effet ce 31 mars de nos vins de
nouvelles expériences ou de nouveaux
monuments à découvrir cette saison du
coup les nouvelles expériences en effet
pas ce qu'on propose à nos visiteurs de
découvrir le parc autrement on leur
propose un guide conférencier de choix
cette année puisque stéphane bern aura a
prêté sa voix pour découvrir douze
monuments sur le site et on a trouvé ça
tout à fait légitime d'avoir monsieur
patrimoine sur france miniature puisque
évidemment présent tous les plus beaux
monuments de france et vous l'avez dit
c'est surnaturel est vraiment
indispensable pour le parent pour
restaurer les pièces refaire quelques
années ce genre de choses c'est vraiment
un vrai travail pendant plusieurs mois
de toutes les équipes qui sont mobilisés
là dessus c'est ça ses différents
métiers sur le parc des maquettistes les
techniciens les maçons les peintres
c'est vrai qu'il ya un gros travail il
ya les aléas préparé il y avait aussi il
faut pas oublier mais france miniature
c'est aussi un énorme jardin
donc on a on a là aussi cinq hectares de
jardins à entretenir c'est un gros
travail pendant cette coupure divers et
c'est vrai qu'on essaie de faire en
sorte que ça soit le plus beau possible
pour l' ouverture des jardins notamment
justement pour accueillir les hôtes
j'espère qu'ils achètent donc il faut
tout son possible c'est ça parmi les
nouveautés donc là ça date de l'an
dernier mais c'est une zone qui est
devenu vraiment importante pour le parc
pour ceux qui ne l'ont pas encore vu
vous avez la salle du conseil de fort
boyard désormais c'est ça on propose à
nos visiteurs en fait de deux dit être
immergé dans l'émission télé et de
défier les maîtres du temps donc le père
fouras père qu'elle propose quelques
énigmes il faut les découvrir et puis
après il faut affronter les maîtres du
temps et donc il ya des jeux d'awalé des
jeux de réflexion des énigmes à trouver
et puis après il ya une étape finale où
on propose à nos visiteurs et bien un
peu d'action et sera une poutre géante
avec des cotons tiges géants on essaye
de de se bousculer et le dernier à
rester sur la poutre a gagné et vous
continuez à développer un justement
cette attraction
on essaye en effet puisque c'est une
attraction qui plaît énormément
l'émission est très regardée et le fort
plaît énormément aux petits aux enfants
mais à toutes les tout le monde aux
familles et on essaye de prolonger cette
expérience on a intégré cette année un
jeu que les enfants pourront télécharger
et pour prolonger justement cette
expérience de visite on propose aussi à
l'issue de cette visite de fort boyard
de scanner un qr code et de rentrer dans
le fort lui-même avec une vue à 360 sur
le smartphone pouvant pour pouvoir les
découvrir parce qu'on rappelle qu'il
n'est pas ouvert aux visites c'est ça il
des firmes et et c'est vrai que ça pose
beaucoup de questions parmi les
monuments les régions les attractions
alors quelles sont celles qui
rencontrent le plus de succès à part
fort boyard du coup dernièrement fort
boyard évidemment mais c'est en effet il
ya des monuments phares qui plaisent
davantage à nos visiteurs ceux qui sont
le plus exposés ceux qui sont les plus
connus et puis après nos visiteurs
viennent de la france entière
donc certains aiment à retrouver le
monument le plus proche de chez eux
maintenant c'est vrai qu'il ya quand
même quelques stars sur le parquet
notamment la tour eiffel le château de
versailles
fort boyard encore une fois le mont
saint michel il ya quelques monuments
qui en est fait plaise à nos visiteurs
encore davantage les incontournables et
donc vous accueillez plus
180 en 1195 mille visiteurs par an mais
l'idée de france miniature c'est
vraiment de conserver cette structure à
taille humaine de rester de garder ce
côté familial vraiment c'est un parc
pour les familles c'est un parc pour les
enfants c'est c c'est vraiment un parc
qui est ouvert le plus grand nombre
possible et c'est vrai qu'on a accueilli
195 milles visiteurs l'année dernière et
on avait accueilli 174 mille visiteurs
en 2016 donc on a eu un progrès cette
progression qui est sensible on a parlé
de ce week-end de réouverture avec la
chasse au sommet vous organiser d'autres
événements alors qu'elles sont quelques
rendez-vous peut-être à noter cette
saison alors chaque année on ouvre un
calendrier à nos visiteurs pour
découvrir le parc autrement des
découvertes autour du miel et des
abeilles puisqu'on a des ruchers sur sur
site et on propose un certain nombre
d'animations qu'on met en ligne sur
notre sur notre site internet
il ya des rendez-vous en effet
incontournable ce qu'on a développé
cette année c'est un cahier jeux pour
les enfants où on propose un parcours
sur site avait plein d'énigmes à
résoudre et et ça sera en place tout le
monde la saison donc à venir découvrir
en tout cas merci beaucoup marqué ça la
loi est revenue sur le plateau de cette
fille de loisirs nombreux rappels france
miniature rouvre ses portes ce week-end
à ne pas manquer
l'ensemble des informations et pour plus
de détails sur le parc rendez vous sur
le site internet merci beaucoup fabrice
lalaut ainsi qu'une figure du cirque
contemporain johann le guillerm
présentera son spectacle secrète en 2h
jouy en josas du 31 mars au 12 avril
il défie les lois de la physique pour
proposer une réflexion philosophique sur
l' équilibre une création proposée par
le théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines
mélanie poker et nicolas landry l'ont
rencontré
[Musique]
savant plasticien équilibristes johann
le guillerm c'est un peu tout cela à la
fois son spectacle sécrétant 2 est à
l'image de son créateur en mélange
d'arts du cirque et de physique
à une époque je me suis j'ai voulu faire
un point sur mes croyances des
connaissances et j'ai ouvert un
observatoire autour du pot grand chose
donc éteint l'observatoire à tour du
point en me disant que si j'arrive à
comprendre de quoi était fait pas grand
chose je retrouverai forcément ce pas
grand chose dans n'importe quelle chose
plus complexes et j'ai ouvert des
multiples chantiers en regardant ce
point qui m'ont amené à rencontrer des
choses comme la mathématique les
géométries la philosophie la topographie
etc
des connaissances acquises en
autodidacte elles ont permis de
concevoir ce spectacle en 2001 une
recherche en perpétuelle évolution
à chaque fois je fais une mutation je
garde faille à la moitié du spectacle se
renouvelle complètement
il ya un quart qui reste de l'ancien
spectacle et un quart qui revient du
précédent faux dernier spectacle
j'espère montrer à porter en tout cas
une forme de
de déstabilisation qui est la direction
de mon travail mouvement torsion du
corps et de la matière une perte
d'équilibré né de la rencontre entre
science et poésie comme pour nous
rappeler que l'existence il ne tient
qu'à un fil
[Musique]
et la culture ce n'est pas forcément
pour les plus grands à saint quentin en
yvelines
on l'a bien compris le rendez-vous des
juniors d'aujourd'hui d'aujourd'hui va
aux gens qu amy pendant deux semaines
c'est babillage le festival pour les
tout petits qui commença dès la
naissance les médiathèques de
l'agglomération ont concocté un planning
qui fourmille de petits rendez vous pour
les bambins
cette année c'est la sixième édition et
ça parle de l'image fixe du pop up vous
savez qu'elle peut être ces livres qui
une fois ouvert présente leur image en
volume en 3d et c'est la spécialité de
l'invité d'honneur philippe hugues j'ai
écouté
en particulier il fait des livres pop up
donc ligue en a qui sont faits par le
plus grand nombre qui sont faits par
annie ducasse mais il ya aussi des
livres qui sont vraiment et les objets
d'art et certains à l'image parce qu'il
est fait chez lui en exemple être très
très limité c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique ça donne envie celle approche
aussi du congé l'approché de l'histoire
même pour le flou quand ça rappelle
aussi des souvenirs on en avait tous un
quand on était enfant donc le compte
c'est le peuple vont se décliner en
plusieurs rendez vous pendant ces quinze
jours il va y avoir des spectacles il va
y avoir des comptes ça se passe
notamment de laurence canto qui
médiathécaires ceux là sont à vivre d un
an
la conteuse catherine la veille elle
vous entraîne dans les aventures de
drôles de personnages qui sont sortis
tout droit d'un chapeau et les futurs
mélomanes pourront aussi s'amuser que
les mots et les rythmes grâce à
l'association portée musicale
alors il y a des dizaines de rendez vous
pour être sûr de ne rien manquer il faut
pas hésiter à consulter le programme
il est accessible sur le site internet
des médiathèques et les parents donc ne
sont pas oubliés car une conférence est
organisée la la rencontre elle est
prévue le mardi 10 avril de 14 heures à
17 heures les parents vont ainsi pouvoir
échanger que l'invité d'honneur philippe
huchet il sera accompagné de
l'association mixage fous ils parlent
ils parleront notamment des nouvelles
formes d'interactions avec les
tout-petits autour de l'image comme sur
le thème avec la cette fois les tapis
enchanté ce sont des tapis interactif
qui prennent vie grâce à un projecteur
de vidéos pour de nombreux rendez vous
les
inscriptions sont indispensables comme
on l'a dit n'oubliez pas de vous
inscrire sur le site internet cette
sixième édition de babillages se déroule
jusqu'au 14 avril
toutes les informations sont disponibles
sur le site internet avec babillage la
parole est donnée aux tout-petits merci
mélanie mais c'est 8 loisirs est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis nous espérons que vous avez fait
le plein d'idées sorties en famille ou
entre amis n'y pour le week-end
on se retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro et d'ici là je vous
souhaite un excellent week end
[Musique]
oh